alright we're live welcome everybody now
the google hangout super excited to be
here with my special guest Amy from sexy
sorry savvy sexy social and we're
talking today about how to stand out on
social media Amy welcome aboard hey Evan
don't worry everybody gets it wrong
mostly just the men no men get the men
wanna see sexy first it they do they
like so sexy first housing sexiest
official I like it I got it um so Amy
and I met on Tim Schmoyer 'he's youtube
entrepreneur series and we were together
for what 12 weeks was at 12 weeks yeah
it was it was it was quite the little
campaign I loved it that was fun and so
for people who may not know who you are
on my channel you want to give them a
quick intro and what you're doing you're
your new vlog series everything's
happened on your channel yeah sure I
have a channel that's called savvy sexy
social I essentially just help empower
personalities to embrace who they really
are and share with the world so whether
that's through video or social and a lot
of people come to me for vlogging and
YouTube advice and it's fun to kind of
share that information a lot of small
business as well as just individuals who
enjoy sharing the media I love it and
when we were chatting you had just done
you know you're just getting to the
vlogging and you're done it before and
if they can maybe I'm gonna do more of
this now you seem to be all into the
vlogging yeah you know it's funny i
think that i think the mantra for 2016
for me so far is like screw the rules
because i think they're in I I tend to
think a little bit black and white
because I'm like okay I know this works
and I'm gonna keep doing that and and I
think sometimes you have to keep things
interesting even if you have set a
certain expectation for your brand
online and it just keeps people
interested in keeps them guessing and so
that's all I'm trying to do is just like
screw the rules like let's try something
completely new and so far it seems to be
pretty well received I think when you
start to build a community as amazingly
as I have been able to they want to
start to see a different side of you so
like me doing something silly like
building book
shelves in my living room seemed to go
over just fantastically and so I know
where do you get just wrenching out to
help entrepreneurs where do you get the
the confidence to say screw the rules
because a lot of people you know they
don't have that you know the guts to
reach it how come people find their
inner Amy and say you know what I don't
care anymore i'm just gonna do it where
did that come from trust me saying the
words out loud gives me just like a tiny
bit of anxiety like I totally understand
why that might be the case but I think
when you get to a point especially in
entrepreneurship where the rules seem to
be breaking all the time and the other
things that we have to keep caring about
what we do and keep doing it really well
and keep differentiating and keep being
better than everyone else on a daily
basis and we have to love it because
every day is not going to be sunshine
and rainbows sometimes it's going to be
horrible but we still report to
ourselves we still have to wake up every
day and do the thing so I think what it
came down to was um there are a lot of
things that are tried and true and
absolutely work and you should use those
and learn from those but the things that
aren't working and maybe there are
things that everyone says you're doing
it right you're doing it right but if
they're not working for you like break
the rules what's the big deal you're
going to learn another lesson like when
it comes down to it we're learning every
step of the way and what about things
though like because what you're doing
was working too right it's not like it
wasn't working it was working but now
you're adding this thing on top of it
can the what has worked now become also
an anchor for you to prevent you from
going forward and how do you gonna break
out of that box yeah I think so i think
what you know works is great because
it's like you can always go back to it
right but i think again like just any
time you can keep your audience guessing
is a good opportunity they know you well
so if you can stay within those those
lines of how you've defined your brand
and you don't go too far away from that
I mean I'm not talking about like one
day she talking about social media
advice and being like hey guys today
we're going to talk politics like that's
a completely different story you stay
true to the brand but you offer
different perspectives of it and I think
that means you can go
back to all to what's old or too what is
definitely tried and true or what still
works but be able to experiment because
that's what's going to keep people
interested in like the standard for a
while I was just standing in front of a
white wall and I'm thinking you know
after a while my friends are just gonna
get tired of it doesn't matter how great
the social media hack is going to be
sometimes they just want to see me out
in the wild as crazy as that might sound
so I just think it's it's good to know
what works keep it in the Arsenal but
build that Arsenal and build all the
different ways that you can communicate
your message out in the wild game you
could be a series that oh my gosh don't
look I go get my makeup huh so the topic
today is about how to stand out on
social how to how to make an impact what
what advice do you give to entrepreneurs
I know it's part of the theme of your
channels to help people who are trying
to get started in social too how can
people stand out on social what advice
do you give them I think the thing is
always the same it doesn't matter what
the platform is so I'm just going to say
a blanket statement at first and if we
want to dive deeper we can to stop
thinking about it as I want to be
amazing on a platform and start thinking
about it as I'm talking to people in a
specific environment it's going to be a
complete game changer for you and the
reason why I point that out is I think a
lot of people are like great if I create
YouTube videos and I have facebook
content Instagram content I can do
snapchat can do this but the reality is
if you're not thinking about them as
different they're all like different
parties they're different places they
have different dress codes different
people different things and you have to
look at them that way so although you
might create one piece of content and it
can serve all of those places you also
have to think about how people want to
receive it while they're there so I
think to stand out in social means to
simply respect the context of every
platform because they are essentially an
environment that you're walking into
that you don't own and that you need to
go wildly impress people so they'll care
about you and move to a real estate
that's yours like your website or your
email list so maybe in the context of
YouTube what what what advice would you
give people who are trying to stand out
on youtube
cat videos are great i think the start
there i just gave me in the wild it's
not god oh we're gonna have a whole
thing by the office uh i think the
reality is that YouTube still although
we're seeing incredible things in the
news about this becoming almost well it
is a mainstream platform to watch
content on it's also really the home of
where we've been able to upload moments
in our lives home videos that we can
share with the world and so that's a
very specific cadence to enter into it's
an decadence of relatability so that's
why I feel sometimes the the commercial
style video isn't going to work because
maybe it worked on TV or whatever you
measure is working on TV but it's not
going to work on youtube because that's
not what people are here to do now I
think that that continues to change but
it's it's true that when you go to
youtube it's a space of relatability you
should not feel like it has to be
perfection all the time and high
production because it doesn't have to be
you can shoot with a smartphone and have
a successful channel you don't even have
to open up an editor and that's a
possibility so that's I feel very hard
for people to get when they've come to
the conclusion that they do need to take
youtube seriously they immediately go
from like zero to 100 like zero we're
not doing it at all a hundred we're
gonna do it all and it's you can work
your way up and your audience is gonna
actually like you more I can't tell you
how many times I get the comment you
know I was so overwhelmed watching your
channel and wanting to resemble you know
your your professional videos and or
whatever the case your your personality
and then I went back and watched your
first video and that's it that's why you
don't delete the old stuff because the
audience likes to see the journey I
agree I look back at my first videos and
you're so bad I want to take them off
but people I think your hardest on
yourself mature other people are too
what was your first video about my first
well my first video ever and I actually
told this story for the first time
and on the stage at social media
marketing world was a video that I made
for a bride I was in her bridal party
and that's literally how I picked up a
camera for the first time I was I was
the last to be picked to be a bridesmaid
because the last actual last bridesmaid
got pregnant and wasn't gonna fit into
the dress they're like leave will you
step in and I was like okay so I was the
last bridesmaid but I wanted to be the
favorite bridesmaid and I just got this
idea about okay I've got this canon
powershot there's a video option I'm
just gonna go shoot a bunch of clips of
people wishing her well that we went to
high school with which was so long ago
because this is like at age 20 and it
was going to be this groundbreaking
thing and it was incredible to me people
in the room like the emotion in the room
it was the rehearsal dinner I played the
video at and just being able to see
these people react to such a crappy
video but feel so emotionally like
driven by it I couldn't get enough of it
so I just started sharing you know
moments with my friends on a YouTube
channel and that's how it started so if
we go back to the channel can we find
that video it's all on the Sh'ma tastic
channel my first channel was the Schmidt
tastic channel yes you can find all of
them you can even find that apparently i
exported the files in some really weird
HD that now YouTube has like it's
distorted like it's not even embedded in
YouTube correctly is how bad it is like
it's it's bad i might go check it out
i'm curious [ __ ] it's pretty hilarious
so we got some questions coming in Percy
is asking Evan and Amy if you have to
choose between quality or quantity on a
daily post basis which is better well I
think I think once you've set a standard
for your channel you stick with it it
could be both quality and quantity so if
if you're saying you're going to show up
every day you better show up every day
um but if you're saying you're going to
have a high production or a certain set
or a certain situation every single
video then you have to deliver on that
so I think it could be both if I had to
choose I think its quantity
because I think you're on e audience
just wants you to show up because
there's so many times I just saw a
channel today that's like wow I'm
growing so fast and it's only been a
year I'm gonna take a break now it's
just what my god that's crazy to me if
you say you're going to show up to show
up and I think your audience on YouTube
specifically cares more about the
showing up than the quality yeah and I
would also differentiate between quality
of like the gear in quality of you on
camera yeah right like if you're great
you know your work on getting better you
can just shoot like a me site with the
phone and not have to have a
professional videographer come in and
shoot it and the quantity will help you
lead to the quality like definitely that
100 videos before I got before wasn't
embarrassed by watching myself 700 Amy
got there probably faster I just got
over an episode of it 700 videos along I
haven't even gotten to that on savvy
sexy social yet so wow it's a lot of
quantity um so yeah so I mean it for me
like my agent had me do my story and I
have to do it 40 different times before
you let me put it up because then I can
do it again do it again do it again so
the quantity will help you become better
you need to get better like your first
first time you try anything you're gonna
suck so then Franco that's that's in my
curriculum like yours are near first
video yeah it's gonna suck like that's
why you have to have one you have to
have the first video you have to watch
yourself back you if you have to edit it
that's even better cuz you really learn
how to get better when you're editing
because as long as it takes you to edit
yourself you're like man I gotta be
better next time I don't have time for
this you know it's it's a practice thing
it's a practice Maureen is asking to
follow up question how do I make a
livestream stand out what advice would
you give marine well I think in the
subscription feed I mean you need to I i
would get fancy with the thumbnail like
just because it's maybe I wouldn't even
say what you're doing here is easier
than a normal piece of content i think
live streams require their own fair
share of work just like an edited
do but I think a lot of live streams end
up not having a custom thumbnail for
some reason and I just don't see why you
wouldn't like I think that they're
really useful for drawing the eye in
because you still have to compete with
other content either way so I don't do
you use custom thumbs your live streams
are no I'm feeling very sheepish because
I didn't even know you could do a custom
thumbnail for a live stream oh I
definite yeah oh yeah that's so funny
Evan because the first live stream that
I did for savvy sexy social not the
first but like the first of recent
that's worth talking about um I know I
have a custom thumbnail on that but I
learned about the fact that I should
even do it on the video entrepreneur
show that we were doing so I only did it
very recently oh now I feel even worse
because if that came up while i was on
the program then I that they can compute
that that was possible no I think I just
took a cute I just was learning for cuz
we had so many live stream experts on
the show and I just feel like I haven't
dabbled in it enough like I've dabbled
in like the apps but less on on youtube
live which is really unfortunate because
this is my main social networks my main
content hub so yeah I think that I think
that the thumbnails help but it's it's
always about how good is your content
and also don't let the headlines just
follow the wayside either like hey I'm
live is not compelling and that's why
Evan was like what are we talking about
because we need to really have a
headline chosen for this that people are
going to care about that's gonna bring
people into right right the initial
headline for this was a me happy face
yeah it would entitle in here oh please
yeah it's coming I think too with with
setting up live events one I would say
you know make sure you're talking that
you're excited about right like I was
excited to having me come on and want to
do so do you guys remember the
conversation you gotta be excited but
the content you're going to be creating
and then promotion side when you set up
a live event you can also make sure that
notifies your subscribers and also puts
up notifications on your channel when
you go live or an hour before or two
hours or four or 24 hours or force you
can start really promoting it I think to
a lot of the other stuff Amy does to you
can set up a newsletter and you know get
people
leave you know your YouTube channels
help your newsletter and then when you
have something you learn on promote like
a livestream you can have them you know
put out to your newsletter say hey I'm
talking to Amy come and join us yeah um
it's all those super helpful uh Luke is
right in to say or Luc Luc is getting
philosophic honest here finally joints
at first this is this is the great part
about hosting you get that pic who
ancestors Lucas saying what what do you
think evident Amy what's the difference
between arrogance and self-confidence
some people think I'm arrogant even
though I'm just trying to be more self
confident i would say the differentiator
is who's talking to you because what
you're arrogant to somebody who is
either maybe a little jealous of what
you got going on or they just don't
understand you they just speak a
different language and i think your self
confident to somebody that really
believes in you or somebody that just
respects the work i think i honestly
think that most of the time these words
end up coming from somebody else's level
of understanding you know like the same
thing with like a woman being bossy
right like that's coming from somebody
that doesn't want to be bossed around
usually and that's how they feel they're
being treated so that's why you get
called that name i think it's important
to know what people are saying about you
because if you have a brand that's
something that's important to note but i
also think that it should encourage you
to be better even if that means
continuing to do what you're doing
because it could just be that you're
doing a heck of a job and and people
wish that they were at least executing
at the same level that you might be
interesting have you been called bossy
no i just think that's like the
comparable in terms of like the woman
space right like we don't like to be
called bossy because it could just mean
that we're being assertive and why
aren't we allowed to be assertive as
women you know like instead of emojis
and exclamation points in my email i
could just write a sentence and that
would be okay all right you know i don't
have to be nice about it i can just be
matter-of-fact about it but there's just
like this weird connotation with like
the way women handle themselves it's
probably
digging ourselves into our own little
hole but I think the same effect happens
as well with the names that get called
to anybody is just other people's
perception of you I like the answer look
so Luke love the two is he's all capping
thank you I love your answer so there
you go you got to go check her out in
her YouTube channel savvy sexy social um
yeah for me I think it's also i see self
confidence as being more internal and
arrogance is uh you're kind of comparing
yourself to others like I'm better than
that guy or I'm better than that girl
we're self-conscious come from yourself
like I know I can do this um I don't
know I think I think arrogance has a
degree of putting other people down with
self-confidence doesn't have to go back
that's that makes a lot of sense yeah so
you can be confident your abilities
without would happen to put others down
I don't know I don't spend a lot of time
thinking about these things yeah well
you don't seem right like you I don't
care things today oh yeah what labels
people put on you just because I'm doing
your thing right uh Steve 0 cubed what
if you kind of hate social media can you
still make it oh yeah I think there's a
lot of people that hate social media
that are amazing at it and they're
probably the ones that differentiate
themselves the most um i think i would
ask yourself why you hate it and try to
dig a little bit deeper on it because
it's one thing to be like screw facebook
they've got old everybody's information
but they don't have mine like if it's
just sort of like the man that bothers
you then like I don't really know where
to direct you but if you don't like
social media cuz you don't like talking
to people like that's an issue like
maybe we should address that and is that
going to affect you in the long run
probably so that's the bottom line I
this is simply a way to communicate
that's it and people abuse it just like
they abuse anything else and people are
successful at it just like people are
successful at anything else so you can
hate social media um you can hate
talking on the phone you can hate
talking in person like what is the thing
about it that you don't like yeah
I think you could also mean to Amy's
point guard at the top every social
media platform has its own cadence has
its own context and you will probably
have more fun and get more value out of
one over the other based on your
personality and type of content that you
like to create you know I love you to
bits where I live I haven't really
gotten in the Instagram or snapchat I
just can't you know maybe maybe that
happen maybe if I talk to Amy a little
more oh my god I can just like I can
work on both but like I could totally
see the way well didn't you say you
don't have a phone though nah I don't
okay but if you didn't if you don't have
a phone like a kid you can't really do
snapchat but you should do snapchat
because I could just see like Evan
having this story of like just
motivational story on snapchat and it
would be killer for people to be able to
watch that story on the fly is just a
new way to watch us plus snapchat
basically took the vlogger jump cut and
made it accessible for everybody else
like that's literally what snapchat
stories is so it's so inherently in line
with youtubers it's it's pretty cool
yeah I think I prefer to do uh either
these like streams of consciousness
interview kind of things or set videos
and I I i have set times that i do my
stuff at and I don't like the 10-second
here thing I haven't gotten into it yet
I'm it maybe maybe I'm really missing
the boat i know i know our mutual friend
Gary Vee is all in on this and is a huge
fan and I mean an Instagram took off and
I was not part of the Instagram craze so
I think I think we're going to answer
that question Steve oh I at least from
my perspective they're probably social
networks that you will just gravitate
towards more you'll have more success at
that just fit your personality more that
you could be a star any of them and I
think too and people try to do
everything and suck it all of them and
that is not clear how to do it acts and
not something that if you take anything
away from this standing out on social
media means pick one and crush it like
the reason why you haven't worried about
these other networks is because YouTube
is social search and content in one
place so
you're on one network and you crush it
and then then you think about how you
can expand these efforts to many times
i'm texting with a client that they're
like okay we got this up and running and
that up and running i think snapchats
next I'm like maybe we should actually
have those other things running not just
up and running let's let's do an amazing
job there let's be so good there's
people there that are like I'll follow
you wherever you go and then start
operating on another social network and
doing different content just spreading
yourself thin is the worst thing you
could do if you actually want to stand
out on social media my audience has
given me flack for my answer they saying
Scandinavian today saying I could
include snapchat into a schedule all
right baby anything anything can be on
your schedule if you really want it to
be it's the schedule that's like the
Bible that you have to follow it's like
getting to be on the calendar is the
thing all right you guys you guys are
making me feel awkward here pushing me
on here it's good though it's good um
sheesham was asking about for making a
video should you just do the video or
plan for a good video what works better
for youtubers I think it's both and I
think there are many levels of this I
mean I know creators who have to read a
script for a video and that just blows
my mind but they end up being very good
and if that's their thing because they
get stage fright with the camera then
that's their thing I personally believe
in looking at the camera like it's a
person and I would not be able to read a
script effectively if that if that were
the case so there is an element of that
that becomes just go ahead and make the
video but that's taken a lot of practice
where I can say okay today I want to
talk about this I know I could talk
about this for five minutes no problem
so I'm going to get in front of the
camera and just talk I'll probably
bullet points bullet point a few things
make sure that I keep my tangents in
line and my calls to action and things
but um preparation is all about you know
like where are you with your
understanding of the content do you need
a lot of direction
then just going from there I prepare for
everything is just a matter of what the
content is and what needs to be
accomplished with the product that is
the case you know preparation for a live
stream like this is me just popping on
and talking to you but preparation for a
video that maybe you would have asked me
to publish on that that's a completely
different situation yeah I think it
depends to me echoing these find them on
how well you do with life stuff uh I I
now tell people want to interview me not
to ask me not to send me the questions
in advance I don't want to know what the
questions I'd much rather it be
spontaneous in live I get more excited
about it when if I think about it then
my interest in to be more I don't know I
feel like the energy passion on the
exact same page I haven't gotten to a
point where I haven't like they'll send
the questions anyway and I'm just like
these are nice I didn't read them though
so i'll just talk to you later well
people freak out back same way yeah
people that makes them feel
uncomfortable uh so if they send the
question that I just don't read them in
go a lot of guests can handle yeah i
got'em mm-hmm let's go and when you want
to read a script i'm the same as amy i
just did a collaboration with brian
tracy and and we had a set intro insect
conclusion and then five points and the
intro and conclusion we only a couple
sentences long but i had to do it 15
times because I could never get the
exact words that I supposed to say too
much Brian and in the five points it
just Bam Bam Bam and bear so I think you
got to find your own young cadence not
not as many people think are good though
at the live part I think it's add some
comfort to be able to script it a little
bit and it just takes practice my first
videos i read an entire script and and i
was even on camera just my voice is
because i couldn't remember you seen on
camera like looking up to my yeah sigh
like oh it was the exact word but it's
far more much about the emotion behind
the words and the exact words that you
say uh does your significant other or
friends make you feel bad about spending
too much time on video
how do you balance that out I don't put
anyone on video that doesn't already
sort of like know that they signed up
for it my friends have probably never
seen me talk to a camera because when
I'm hanging out with my friends I'm
hanging out with my friends um so I
think it just depends on this scenario
you you do have to it's sort of like
everybody saying now that everyone's on
their phones too much that could
absolutely be the case but you as the
individual using the phone and why
you're using it in the moment that
you're in is it all needs to match up so
if you're just ignoring everybody in
your on your phone that's silly but if
you're using your phone for a good
purpose then great if I'm taking video
while I'm around my friends and my my
significant other and it's because it's
something I need to document they should
just know in advance that that's going
to be the case otherwise it's just sort
of random if I'm just like pulling a
camera out for no reason although
personal vloggers probably do that more
often if your friends and family feel
like that is the case I have known
youtubers that ended up not doing it
anymore because that was the case and I
just think it ends up being a
conversation you have to have the
conversation with people they're not
gonna be able to get into your head and
understand why you're documenting
everything but you also need to have a
line where you'll respect everybody else
it's in your life and be the off-camera
person that they know you to be as well
yeah you mean you look at our mutual
friend Gary Vee again and he's on camera
so much everything is so public and so
personal but he doesn't put his kids on
and that was something that he and his
wife kind of agreed to and so his kids
aren't you'll talk about them but
they're never actually in any of his
videos so you just got to understand the
line with the people in your life you
know he said how did this is any other
or friends ever make you feel bad about
spending too much time on video I kind
of sense like this is also a hobby of
his or passion of his and maybe his
girlfriend or family members are making
them feel bad for doing something he
wants to do and if that's a case you
know you it was something that you're
really passionate about you want to do
you you may be with the wrong person to
you know yeah and that's
that's that's a tough thing to realize
and that that's a tough conversation to
have but it's a very real experience
that I've had in my life and just
knowing when it's time to say this is
important to me and I really want to
focus on this and I really sorry Lucy's
giving me an Amen back here um I want to
do this if you have people in your life
that don't respect that then it's going
to be really hard for you to follow your
passion because you do need to feel
supported and sometimes feeling
supported means walking away from people
that aren't going to support you last
question a very serious note there it's
but I agree I totally agree I'm cool
where I mean we're bumping up against
the clock tons of more questions coming
on the live chat amy has covered a lot
of the questions you guys are asking on
her channel if you want to go check it
out i've linked it up in the description
Amy any last words you want to leave the
audience with believe believe you can
stand out on social media people you can
do it no it's great just remember who
you're talking to because that's what
you're doing camera social your fans
your friends your family anyone like
what is the moment that you're in and
what is the content and talk to that
person because this is how you dance on
the line this is how you create YouTube
videos that benefit hundreds of
thousands of millions of people and this
is how you affect your family is by
sitting in the moment and having a
conversation with that it's all content
it's all you being you and it's how you
stand out I love it Amy thank you for
the time thank you guys for watching go
check her out savvy sexy social
description continue to believe and
we'll see you soon thanks guys